this drawing is a wormhole between two
flat two-dimensional houses light will
be funneled in through one end and then
splayed out in a circle on the other
side a round window to another world in
our three-dimensional World these entry
and exit points would instead be spheres
light from one room will be funneled in
through the fourth dimension and then
splayed out in a sphere on the other
side it would be a spherical window to
another world it would look a bit like
the reflection in this Christmas
ornament except instead of seeing a
distorted version of myself I would see
the person in the other room waving back
at me